[Music]
i can't tell are the players
chit-chatting is that what's going on
the game is starting no one get no one
told me except you michelle thank you
oh damn you and you're sicilian i hate
the sicilian oh my god he knows the
names
yeah are more than i do wait they're
they're just trying to talk
about what to do here
this is bad because he's going to push
it again and then reopen that diagonal
yeah we may have a we may have a new
favorite this is a
pretty harsh harsh opening but man this
is a brutal start oh my gosh this is
really rough
oh no oh no oh no oh no
[Music]
it's everything that we thought was
going to happen yes
the bishop opens up again he just gets
the bishop out and
i don't even know what i'm playing
anymore this is so strange
that is unfortunately how it works
sometimes
it's how i feel when i play hikaru
the only public game on this profile
that he has
is against magnus carlsen that's it
like clearly he plays somewhere else on
something else he's gotten coaching he
obviously works with uh
you know danny talked yesterday about
how he's had a long relationship with
chess and chess.com
we know nothing about the guy it's like
in a video game hikaru
where you know nothing about a boss and
the recent you know
article on the website or newspaper the
the mo
like the book hasn't been published how
to beat that boss so you just keep
trying
i feel like i lose no matter what i do
here i don't even
if i go here he goes here
[Music]
and this is such a
difficult scenario
i feel like i just have to go here now
there's literally nowhere for me to go
i have no idea what else i'm supposed to
do no idea
it made the game go longer so we'll see
what happens oh no and now he's going to
go work do you want to queen the egg
is he actually going to do that or is he
going to take on a phase stop
okay if he plays rook d1 okay he just
takes the bishop
good okay good at least at least he
didn't play rook do you want to queen
the eight made okay
he literally would have had i mean that
would have been the problem would have
been like a 99
cap score for accuracy i think yes very
close to it
yes rookie one was mate in two it is
still
it is still game over rook d1 is
probably still the professional move
here i mean
and unbelievable not even knight e5 not
even 95 which a lot of people would play
just chasing the king
crazy pretty harsh pretty pretty harsh
is he going to play queen e8 preventing
the escape to beef oh my god he prevents
the king from escaping
he doesn't even give a check wow
so who's going to call danny and tell
him that
he might have messed up with this
invitation
oh no and queenie seven and rook d8 oh
yeah yeah
this is i hope he hasn't pre-moved it
that would be even worse
yeah queen d8 and as well as queen v6
with some mates but he just
goodness me geez
brutal first game oh my gosh harsh
wow how was your day going
my day's good yeah i i i
exercised today michelle there you go
yeah yeah i ran around and lifted some
weights
i took a shower you look great
i'm well groomed well i'm not very well
groomed my hair how about you
what have i been up to um i was what i
was playing chess before this
um oh yeah i took a lesson with my chess
master coach
with danny he's the worst he's a double
agent
he gave me a like i kick his ass every
time he can't even beat me i'm like oh
you're going to lecture me
oh wow i'm just kidding i would believe
that
he's way better she's been
looking at london queen's gambit systems
uh
throughout uh she has a kind of a
a little group chat uh with with myself
with
anna with the other anna anna kremling
but she's done lessons with everybody
because ultimately she is filming
her show and i think she made a big
effort to kind of reach out
uh to the community probably after this
one uh
maybe you'll have to give oh this is
actually
she's getting her old opening played
against her so rayne wilson is a king's
indian guy
interesting she used to play this she
started out with the setup so
all right let's see what happens
wait sorry oh my god
i cannot believe he just did that
i cannot believe he just did that oh no
no oh danny's getting an angry message
he's not getting one now i'm gonna have
to think how to write it but this is not
this will not be
a polite hr email the whole team's gonna
have to get involved
already ah
not even a moment not
even a moment to breathe
yeah this is uh this is unfortunately
one of those things i'm gonna go
uh knight d2 good good open up my queen
yes this is one of those things in
london hikar you get hit with it once
you never get hit with it again this
early queen
ah she might defend her bishop with the
queen and hang the rook that's the
problem
this is unprotected okay so i need to
move this
you're in check i i will say i really do
like the way
i do like the move she's finding like
this is really really rough
um for her but she's still like the she
makes these blunders but she's still
finding a way to find good moves even
after the blunders i think that's really
really important to note
um yes yes like bishop b5 is a very very
good move yes
yes this is exciting for me okay
if she plays knight takes pawn f3 to win
okay i think i'm gonna take with the
knight because it's protected by the
pawn
come on just do it go for it i wish
there was a way i could take
an attack i know
we're listening into her i will just say
uh as someone who has worked with her
even the first chess lesson protect my
work which is nice okay
the first lesson that she ever took uh
and ever since then i've kind of like
i don't think we're gonna get queen f3
though he car i'm not gonna lie i think
she's gonna take back
right but i mean rain is just destroying
everything here like he doesn't he's
getting rid of the great bishop
on that on the dark squares so there's a
lot of danger here for black
queen enough three come on one two good
he's too good three come on i need to
get my rook
she was caught off guard by queen d4 but
she saw it that's the thing like she has
to trust herself she saw it she saw take
stakes
she didn't need to say damn it like that
was gonna happen and now she's winning
but she's in the wrong mindset she's not
thinking i'm gonna beat this guy she's
thinking i gotta survive i gotta
queen f3 aggressive and you win the rook
yeah yeah
okay not the best move but i mean again
oh queen takes what queen takes queen
what
she doesn't even see it she's only
looking at her rook under attack
oh oh she's i think she spotted it she
took
she took its game on oh
what happened see i told you michelle
oh
oh no wow
you got me good are you serious
yeah i just totally blundered i just
didn't even i was just like oh i'll go
over there
it happens
oh my god okay guys
it's game time but now you have six
minutes to meet me
okay i'm just gonna i gotta get my rook
out of the way
and to protection i think i'm gonna go
here puts
in check he can't castle
the only defense is okay there are two
there's that knight
oh my god i need to think michelle just
move
you don't you don't need to think six
moves ahead just go you're up a queen
european
okay okay i can't go here i can't i
can't i can't go there
can't go there can't go there
i can go here oh my gosh she can make
any one of those moves
and it's all those moves are checked so
do i want to go here
[Music]
or here
okay i'm gonna go
b2 i'm thinking b2 because then it
protects this pawn
yes it's also check all right all right
all right all right all right
all right all right all right i mean
sometimes
when you get a gift like that it's hard
to react right because you're winning
and you're like
hold up yeah very very true if she wins
then she gets to play in our first tie
break which we thought we would have
today
actually multiple times
if you go here i go here
oh my god okay i need to calm down
is the living example of all of our
emotions when we play chess okay
maybe not you hikaru but this is i think
as much as we try to contain it
you know what okay
uh i i literally have no idea what else
to do
so i'm just gonna take pawns i know
that's not the best strategy but um
here we are actually no okay
that made sense
i don't know i've done the puzzles guys
i've done the puzzles
okay you know if anything this is a
testament to how hard what is that chess
okay here here to threaten the bishop no
okay i gotta move faster oh she's got
two two minutes oh wait
oh wait here and check you're in check
e5 i all i need all i know how to do is
just put things in check that's all i
know how to do
for now it's fun oh my god jesus christ
the rook is hanging a7 is not good just
because you lose the pawn not because
you lose the rook
right exactly yeah that's oh good move
sharp play from her she's also evolving
throughout this game it feels like
that's it get it out push the pawn it's
over i mean it's
the next wave
i know she sees it yeah
good move
king h4 okay g3 you know what the crazy
she she might put her king in the corner
and get okay no but she has to check the
king here
okay oh this is so close and now he's
gonna try to smother and checkmate
oh that's a great move there you go
that's it just take it
and now it's impossible
now it's impossible but she has to win
no stalemates
and she's definitely done she's
definitely done ladder mates
she's definitely well done michelle
it's not it's not over yet it's not over
it's so good
i'm shaking
great i couldn't i thought i had you
there i did kind of have you but i
flew it again i really blew this game
well done
really good oh thank you this almost
feels like borgov harmon
you know the final scene where he he but
okay please don't bring your
clock perfectly i kicked my
ass i don't want a tubbo situation
hikaru
oh i hope something against logic yeah
that's it yeah congratulations
oh my god that was insane
i have no feeling in my hands
[Laughter]
oh my gosh michelle obama
michelle come youtube come back
for white four minutes for black but if
the game ends in a draw black
is the winner correct likelihood that
happens to win the game
oh yeah this game has gotten oh oh
oh no it's mate if it well
takes and you can't take back yeah
no oh
what a butthole
wow it's so fast
okay 155 the clock is ticking
oh she blundered it back but she gets a
rook but she did blunder it back
right that's true yeah that's true she
michael rook 8 she played
so nervous and now he can take the
knight he does see it
rookie six fork and then knight e7 check
probably a good move by michelle very
very very good move i like the way that
she's playing
throughout this match um even though she
is over match she has found a lot
of good moves they're just c6 yes
and and seven and bishop and queen
just queen and mate queen and mate it
looks like rain wilson's gonna pull it
out
correct yes
all right take the rook and uh
oh what did i do
i'm sorry okay uh where were we left
well looks like he's gonna he looks like
he's gonna finish the game
and well now literally any move and
uh yeah and reigns wow that was
really pathetic oh my god
oh my god nine seconds left
i can't feel my hands oh no
that was uh that was very very much that
was
[Laughter]
wow you played so great you really
played way better than me
honestly really did you had a minute
left
you had a minute less than me i forgot
that
oh my god it's gone less than me she
played great by the way that's all i
want to say
michelle played amazing she like
learned like a month ago or something
like that she watched like queen's
gambit and said i'm going to be
bethlehem
and then she took me to the mat and
played just fantastic especially with
her clock
um that's what she said this is probably
the first
big mental challenge i've had to take on
and let me tell you it's
equally as stressful it is equally as
stressful
as you know rappelling down a tower with
the us marine corps
or doing being in a burning building i
can't feel my hands right now this was
so stressful and with the audience oh my
gosh like
especially in the first game um i i
clearly
made a lot of blunders and had a big
learning opportunity there but
the chess community is incredible i have
loved
um getting to stream chess and learn
from you levy and anna kramling and anna
rudolph
and so many other wonderful people and i
just love how welcoming you guys are
and uh i i'm going to hydrate a lot
after this
[Music]
you